so we're less than a week away from the
fourth of july and today safe insane
fireworks go on sale all across clark
county
this morning hector mejia is live at one
local fireworks stand with an important
reminder about being safe during the
holiday
hector
hey there good morning you've probably
seen these fireworks stands pop up
across the valley outside grocery stores
outside gas stations
and they are important fundraisers for
hundreds of local organizations this one
for example
is fundraising for the local homeless
community but it's also important to
remember what is safe
and legal this time of year the safe and
sane fireworks are the ones that stay
close to the ground
they've been tested and approved by our
local fire departments and only cleared
for you to use them this week any other
time safe and sane fireworks become
illegal along with fireworks that shoot
up into the air
tim symansky with the las vegas fire
department says
what the department typically sees
leading up to the holiday
what we commonly see is people sitting
in a cul-de-sac
and there might be a bunch of lawn
chairs around in a circle and
the people let the kids pick out which
one that they want
next and everybody's watching it
together that's probably the best way to
do it
if you need to report illegal fireworks
do not call 911 unless it's an emergency
instead use the website i spy fireworks
ispyfireworks.com just like last year
local police use that information and
then team up to patrol trouble spots and
obviously police can't be everywhere but
if you do get caught
you could face a fine of between 250 and
a thousand dollars
better be safe and sane than sad and
sorry
reporting live this morning hector mejia
8 news now